meanwhile nancy pelosi again these are
the people you want to lead i'm not
going to stop saying this stop asking
these people to lead you they are
corrupt they don't care about you they
care about their own power they've
convinced themselves they care about you
okay i'm not saying they're not sincere
i'm seeing them delusional they are
sincere they sincerely believe that they
are helping you it just so happens they
help themselves around the edges a
little bit too i mean
it doesn't really matter i mean if you
are they just have to take a taste just
a little taste so nancy pelosi yesterday
jews asked about members of congress
trading individual stocks now i'm of the
belief that once you're in congress you
should not be able to trade on the
information that you receive in congress
okay because if we are going to bar
insider trading for private entities we
should bar insider trading for members
of congress that's because they can in
fact even if you were to allow insider
trading for people in in the private
sector which again i think there's a
kind of libertarian case for that it
actually allows for free flow of
information more free flow of
information
for market response than there otherwise
would be right people actually get
information faster when insider trading
is available but put that aside if
you're a member of congress and you can
actually control policy knowing that you
can get a majority to
do a thing that is going to impact
business in a particular way so you
short sell the business or you know that
a business is about to get a subsidy
because you know it's been formulating
behind closed doors and you control the
system
and so you're using the power of a
democracy to make yourself more rich
that's super duper corrupt nancy pelosi
was asked about this yesterday she of
course has a long history of
questionable insider trading issues and
she was like well we are
we have a free mac assistant hearing
marxist leaning nancy pelosi talk about
what a wonderful free market system we
are
by utilizing government power to make
herself richer is uh pretty vomit
inducing here we go
should members of congress and their
spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks while serving in
congress no i don't know to the second
one
any we have a responsibility to report
in the stock on the stock but i don't
i'm not familiar with that five-month
review but if the people aren't
reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate in that
that's not the question the question is
whether you're participating in a free
market economy or whether you you're
using your regulatory power to get rich
if you're a soviet commissar and you can
dictate
the price of shoes and so you go abroad
and you buy a bunch of shoes and you
sell them in the soviet economy while
dictating the price that is not a free
market and if you're a member of
congress and you're using your
regulatory power to subsidize or crack
down on particular business and then you
are trading in that business at the same
time that is unbelievably corrupt that
is not free market stuff
this has been a long-standing issue with
congress
peter schweitzer has been has been
writing on this for years and years and
years all the way back in 2012 he talked
about congressional corruption newsweek
wrote about it
while examining trades made around the
time of the 2003 medicare overhaul peter
schweitzer experienced what he called
his holy crap moments according to
newsweek the legislation which created a
new prescription drug entitlement
promised to be a huge boon to the
pharmaceutical industry and savvy
investors in the capital among those
with special insight on the issue is
massachusetts senator john kerry
chairman of the health subcommittee of
the finance committee kerry is one of
the wealthiest members of the senate
heavily invested in the stock market as
the final version of the drug program
neared approval one that did not include
limits on the price of drugs brokers for
kerry and his wife were busy trading in
big pharma schweitzer found they
completed 111 stock transactions of
pharmaceutical companies in 2003 103 of
which were buys they were all great
picks choice or notes that carries
capital gains on the transactions or at
least half a million dollars and as high
as two million dollars
it was instructive to schweitzer that
kerry didn't try to shape legislation to
benefit his portfolio the key was that
he knew exactly what the government was
about to do and then he and then he
spent money in order to make money from
it
terry's spokesperson said senator kerry
does not buy sell or trade stocks she
noted that carrie's holdings were in
family trust managed by independent
trustees further kerry was not a
beneficiary of teresa heinz kerry's
trust which were established before they
were married also kerry was running for
president mitch missed much of the
debate but schweitzer says it's not that
i think john kerry is calling up his
broker on healthcare and saying buy the
company sell the company the issue is
one of the double standard he notes that
if the executive of a healthcare company
were in discussions with the white house
over pending legislation that would
affect his industry and then made a
bunch of unusual stock transactions
related to the industry the sec would
probably open an insider trading
investigation it says the only group in
america we exempt as politicians who are
probably the last people about whom we
should be saying oh we'll take their
word for it that's what's so amazing to
me
and this has been a major issue for
years and years and years and years a
bipartisan issue by the way members of
congress who are benefiting from this
sort of insider trading of course nancy
pelosi thinks that that's the free
market
because according to nancy pelosi using
government money to do things she wants
is the free market
and then these are the people that you
trust with you like are you getting the
benefit of their bargain
are you really
and meanwhile speaking of nancy pelosi
and her delusional policies she made a
statement yesterday that's just insane
she was talking about rising crime in
america's major cities
and uh the speaker of the house she said
there's an attitude of lawlessness in
that country and i don't know where it's
coming from
do you not do you not know nancy pelosi
because i feel like you do or you're
completely adult and the moths have made
their home directly in the center of
your medulla oblongata here we go
the fact is that there is an attitude of
lawlessness in our country that springs
from i don't know where
maybe you do
uh no i do i do it's from you
it's from you and your friends green
lighting rioting all of last year you
and your wildly liberal george soros
best prosecutorial friends who have
decided they are going to undermine law
enforcement throughout the united states
like i i know and i think nancy pelosi
does too reality is starting to hit home
for this crew and when it hits it is
going to be ugly so they have two
choices they can burrow deeper into the
delusion or they can realize that joe
manchin is kind of right they can
realize that
they've undermined the full faith and
credit of the united states they can
they can they can recognize that they've
destroyed their own economic hubs
because of their coveted insanity
and through crime right they can
recognize all this or they can just keep
doubling down oddly enough some of them
are starting to recognize it and it's
very weird so for example san francisco
mayor london breed who's a nut in london
breed back to defund the police movement
five seconds ago
and according to daily wire
speaking in a press conference on
tuesday breed erupted at the surging
crime around san francisco
here's what london breed had to say
this time
that the reign of criminals who are
destroying our city it is time for it to
come to an end
and it comes to an end
when we take the steps
to be more aggressive
with law enforcement
more aggressive with the changes in our
policies
and less tolerant
of all the bulk that has destroyed our
city
we are going to turn this around
i mean
she is one of the chief manufacturers of
the bull
like that's a that's a
weird take
so i'm glad that she's come around to
this it is weird to see rudy giuliani
inhabit the body of a black woman that's
strange and she's just talking and all
of a sudden she's morphing through honey
talking about cutting down on crime it's
unbelievable
it's
you know you see the morphing happening
in real time so bizarre maybe reality is
starting to hit because as of last year
she tried to divert 100 million dollars
from the san francisco police department
to social justice programs so yeah
reality is starting to hit
so the question for the democrats is how
fast it hits because maybe the democrats
can pull their chestnuts out of the fire
for 2022 if they allow reality to
intervene but it seems like they're not
going to allow reality to intervene it
seems like they are they are focused in
like a laser beam
on not allowing reality to intervene
on any of these subjects
right a little bit on crime maybe
although eric adams swore in the new
nypd commissioner in front of a of a
mural that included actual cop killers
which is a strange move by eric adams
yesterday in new york
still it seems like in some of the major
cities
the chickens are coming home to roost a
little bit for for democrats nationally
however they've i think they're gonna
have to get walloped first honestly i
think the democrats are gonna have to
lose an election they're gonna have to
lose it in massive fashion
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe